- [Onnia Harris] We had nothing;
it was just condemned land.
You've got something that's dead and ugly
and you just make it beautiful
and that's what they did.
(railroad crossing chimes)
- I think the farthest away I am
from any of the relatives
is seven minutes.
- Hey, Grandma.
(laughs)
- And I like that.
I just like the area.
- It's nice to have the family around
because we right here,
so that's like the best thing.
Pullman, everybody know
as far as the 1800s,
it's known for its railroad cars.
It used to look like a
raggedly neighborhood to me.
- [Grandma] Bye, kids.
- It was hard to get a job in Pullman.
A lot of times by me
being a single parent,
it's hard for mothers to
always be away from they kids.
I used to spend like two
hours just traveling,
trying to get to my job,
but now I've got a job right
in my own neighborhood,
which is great.
Has anyone been to the factory
with all the pretty colors
on the building down 111th?
It's not your normal warehouse.
I'm the one that's responsible
for printing this fine print
on our bottles for Method.
The company is about being yourself
and having fun while you're at work.
Hey, Tony.
Method, they've been here
almost three years now.
For them to come choose this location
was like a blessing to everybody.
I came in with no skills
and they taught me everything
that I need to know.
Hey, Jimmy.
(laughs)
We really come in and help this community.
You know, we bring in people
that's from this area code,
giving them a job,
and we're gonna teach them.
Like, we're not gonna just say,
you're not good enough.
It's a messy job, but
I finally got it clean.
(laughs)
I come in starting off at packing bottles
to running the soap screen.
As long as it's running great, perfect,
but there's some times
where we missing a line here
or the barcode's bad,
that's when I gotta get in with my tools.
Working at that machine
got me feeling handy.
Now I feel like SuperWoman,
all I need is my cape;
that's it.
(laughs)
(pop music)
Everybody say you have
kids at a young age,
you become a statistic,
but they became like
my biggest motivation.
It's just bigger than just,
oh, we're making soap or I just got a job,
they know that Mom working for us.
A lot of people they don't
see all the bigger picture.
My whole family here,
I didn't wanna just leave them
so if I can stay and make a difference
and an impact on the community,
make it better in my own neighborhood.
It not serve purpose just for me,
it'll serve for my family as well.